hey how's Gomes mana back welcome back
to bed rising bed rising haha that's
funny it's actually really funny I saw
me stuck barrel
I didn't worked at it look it's floating
in the [ __ ] air no you're I don't
make out with me just because I have a
dildo that is rude all right here we go
found it oh he's gonna be good flambo
I like the sander there it doesn't make
a sound but I like the sound of [ __ ] if
you know what I mean
alright let's try this um that guy oh
you got a new dick Oh
now injustice plan whoa what is this
what what is that beer and cats how can
this not be awesome Howie how does it
work
that's not how does it work for a cat
but are you going cat kitty stop
breakdancing kitty
goddamn kitty how the [ __ ] does this
work this is not Oh Oh God uh whoa what
the [ __ ] are you doing kid
Kenny will you do it can't it'll leave
me I trusted you get it
kitty kitty stop it kitty kitty what are
you doing all right you guys want to
play pokemon oh god
nothing nothing oh I have the Gandil
staff why didn't no one tell me you're
shall not passenger there you go
bad what the [ __ ] are they doing they're
frozen oh my god oh my god I got the
original frozen here they say
our heads are exploding damn bees are
hipsters they can't take it it's sooo
mainstream no back massage not in the
mood no I'm not on my barrier free
balloons for everyone you want a balloon
I got your back son
there we go where did the balloons come
from oh the salt Super Saiyan then don't
worry about it hey I missed you
what are you doing a get off me car okay
boom beer + wheelchair and push your
bare paws dynamite
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
Eddie shut up I miss you mane
oh there is a wheelchair here oh oh oh
my god just in my pants get a bed get
all those [ __ ] me and Ed are gonna
get married one day you're all just
jealous
they're so jealous and you don't have a
lot of life left I just can't see you
die
I'll just never mind he's dead oh this
gonna be good oh yeah I remember this
from the first game hey yo catch ya hey
you're supposed to catch come on catch
it dad damn you're worse than a Pokemon
ad spend
cleaning the streets from the heaters
making them into favorites balloons hey
lady
hey lady are you a fan of shares I'll
take that as a yes
hey lady are you a fan of video games
bounced right off her hey lady are you a
fan of access all right now you're just
being lucky I catch hey [ __ ] kidding
me
what are you made of rubber that make
for one hell of a booty if you know I'm
saying if you know what I'm saying
oh god damn it every time I love me some
booty alright let's try out their new
weapons hey Sammy's by zambese you want
to go to space free ticket one-way trip
though forgot to mention that
oh man shot it's in the stars now live
long and prosper my friend live long and
prosper that's the thing about Sammy's
they live long not can't touch this
wearing product can touch me and touch
me Prada
sorry Prada coming through what did I
say [ __ ] straight trash oh we got
something here party goes oh no no I
can't I can't
are those DOCSIS fingers cuz I don't
even know how to live then Oh Mary
oh you're holy grace I will lick your
face and something something duck a
glove America freedom this is for ducks
[ __ ] I [ __ ] you up a pop you
want this is how when you were in prison
welcome to America [ __ ] welcome
to America
welcome to America [ __ ] you [ __ ]
with you this is our way doing in
America mother [ __ ] for the Ducks who
wants a free laptop saw it I just need
it but free laptop giveaway first one
dude like this video gets it
whip see that I call it a laptop oh yeah
my mini back is back
oh okay man the graphics in this game
are amazing Wow look at that whoa a
flying box whoa look at these graphics I
love it best graphics I have ever seen
oh yeah I got the babies free abortions
I mean free babies keep mixing this to
us you want a free baby well I guess
some people just can't handle being a
mother someone please adopt Justin
Bieber for me please take him I don't
want him goddamn no one wants Bieber
baby
I don't understand it's a really good
weapon though I'll give him that
how do I get over there how oh I did it
I'm a amazing what have we got tactical
word how do I bomb oh space everyone
goes to space you go to space you go to
space you go to space you gotta face
everyone goes to space I can't oh my god
Joe pick up pick up pick up pick up pick
up [ __ ] don't touch me
nikka power
oh god damn it well it was good as long
as it lasted hey no it's like baby baby
baby oh somebody please adopt his fever
huh
oh sorry I got a little carried away
fine Apple did you see that pine up now
pineapple eight you stupid whoa can I
Drive these oh let me out lift me up
now you don't help me don't [ __ ] my car
like that uncool lift me up lift me up
I'll stop [ __ ] my car
Wow Jade said she went to space why just
happen what up my car is breakdancing
that's that's you see something new
every day
flawless game is flawless Wow oh oh okay
sure why not
get off my car alright alright friends
I'm gonna have to end this episode here
hope you enjoy watching if you did hit
that like button for me and that's all
for me see in the next one
stay awesome bros get off me copper